amazon is adding something unexpected to
its own shopping cart more than 400
locations of the Whole Foods grocery
chain why the Amazon looking to
transform the way we shop for just about
everything
what is the e-commerce giant planning
and could the acquisition change our own
future as consumers there to discuss it
all CBS News contributor and Wired's
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson Nick
good morning morning Anthony what's
Amazon strategy so Amazon is doing a
bunch of things number one they're
getting into groceries it's an area
where there's where they're lagging
where they haven't completely succeeded
where they're losing out to Walmart they
would like to get in this business they
think there's lots of money there
secondly they're buying a bunch of
distribution centers in affluent urban
areas where they can do all kinds of
things in the future and three they're
gradually going to shift the way we buy
things to us ordering things on our
phone and then we come and pick them up
I think that is their vision for how we
do groceries at Whole Foods and
ultimately for how we do lots of other
things too Amazon is sort of toyed
around with brick-and-mortar but this is
a major acquisition over 460 stores I
think I know they kind of kick around
they built this they put robots there
they do this and then suddenly okay yeah
I'm going to buy Whole Foods today 12
billion dollars like practically
speaking do you think the inventory of
the stores changes oh I think absolutely
I think Amazon is really good at math
Amazon is really good at placement I
think the whole food stores will be
transformed Amazon is said oh no we're
not gonna do anything
Whole Foods is gonna be completely
different in two years Wow if you're
your Kroger's or Costco Nick what are
you thinking
today you're thinking oh my god I just
lost 15% of my market cap because
everybody thinks Bezos is the smartest
person in the world and he's gonna come
and crush me yeah I'm I'm furious if I'm
one of those stores it's one of the
craziest things that's happened just as
soon as Bezos spot Whole Foods all of
the competitors went whoosh yeah so I'd
be very worried I'd also think okay I
need to really think about the future of
shopping I need to really get going I
don't know whether it's going to be
removing cashiers saving time there I
don't know whether it's going to be
allowing the customers to pick up the
groceries themselves I don't know
whether it's gonna be different stacking
procedures but I start trying to move
into the future much more quickly well
also where do we talk about the demise
of brick-and-mortar this is a
redoubling of the importance of
brick-and-mortar in certain sectors of
the American economy yeah there's no
question that brick-and-mortar really
matters and food is really important
right because you can't order it from a
warehouse it's kind of hard to drop off
at your doorstep because the Chipmunks
come and eat your food if they leave it
so you know grocery stores are really
important and they're quite different
from shipping electronics Bezos
basically wants to own the whole economy
right you think he will I kind of think
he will I kind of think that in like ten
years Jeff Bezos owns every single thing
there is well it's not entirely true
right but sort of its kind of sort of
true well I mean what is me to that end
space-exploration a newspaper he's
bought now grocery chain what is what's
next in this progression well and also a
reminder that he runs the entire
Internet through Amazon Web Services
which was a crazy bet made ten years ago
and he's done well at all of these
things what's next I mean it's crazy
that he was going to buy I mean we were
all talking about him buying slack
office productivity software right what
company in the same week is like been
billions of dollars on the office
productivity software and a grocery
store right so I don't have any way of
predicting what's next but it will be
something and the difference is that
Amazon finally has cash right Amazon was
not profitable it's basically this stock
deal where the stock market bid it up
and they lost money and everybody kept
bidding it up now they're profitable
they have money so they can start buying
all sorts of stuff it's also possible he
won't be good at this and then possible
awesome probable I don't know right Nick
Thompson thanks so much for being here
thanks for having me